hello and welcome to this video
Apple car loops and yeah okay
it's my opponent so the qga this line
has taken some victims already taken
some victims claimed some victims right
that's the right way to put it
this has some some clear resemblance to
the Carroll right it looks a bit like a
comic-con CARICOM advanced variation
okay now why not yes to take with the
bishop now yeah just develop I think
training Queens should be quite useful
[Music]
I've got a bit of a space disadvantage
so I don't mind - the Queen trade yeah
maybe I can generate some play against
the d4 pawn a little bit surprising that
he wants to trade even more I would
think that any trades help me here as
I've got this clearly defined static
weakness that I can attack so now I'm
FICO b5 + c5
[Music]
okay I can actually just play b5 and c5
there was nothing and much that he can
do against it
you can't go d5 but this is not helping
all that much Bishop takes doesn't work
because of Bishop e6 and if we trade
everything I have Bishop e6 at the end
and this is a very good ending very good
is probably but the W form is erm I'm
just winning I think more or less yeah
it's winning
it's just winning
unless he has some sequence Bishop c6 b4
a3
no no that's winning
I think I winning that should basically
promote loud really okay
[Music]
yeah can point ending with all the
kingís usually a bit of a bit of a non
stardom and his King is just not in play
best to win de paso first yeah I mean he
helped me a lot about all these trades
so we we got this this position here
which is probably about equal at 97
Bishop g5 yeah
I don't mind the trades this is actually
true the engine suggests Bishop g4 and
this is definitely a better move because
if I can take on a three years this is
very desirable something like this it's
nice just got the better structure him
when age six was a bit bit too quickly
played you know and I don't think this
is helping you know he's just agreeing
to all the trades the more we trade the
the more pronounced this weakness
becomes it is not yet so one serious but
after here I don't know how do you keep
this I'm doubling and I mean he did what
he had to do here and now b5 c5 and
that's it this is basically over I
believe in d4 because d5 doesn't cut it
yeah this is immediately immediately
lost loses a piece and now takes a best
move for C form this is true actually
and this is very strong because here I'm
immediately promoting but this is
winning as well I think this is the king
upon anything that we had and the the a
bit more interesting is this after which
before a3 this is what I saw I wanted to
play a five and then see for next so
like this
F for let's aim C form and then this
that was my idea
there's not really anything you can do
we can take clay Bishop a4 okay yeah but
you can do the same take egg I'm not
quite quite quick enough so maybe maybe
this first
okay this is what the engine is giving
this is actually so quite shocking maybe
after b4 a3 I've got something better
and the computer wants to play b3
immediately or g5 this is actually a
simple and good move the idea is to move
this next and then pick up the pawn yes
that's that's a good move
that's a good move yeah okay and the
Kampong ending was was a complete loss
of course okay guys thanks for watching